so when I would look at why are women so
bad it's like okay if you pay women to
be terrible then you're probably gonna
have more terrible women I mean it's
just common sense if you get paid to be
a single mother why wouldn't you break
up your family well I mean morals but
that's a whole nother and a whole nother
thing so so what I figured out when I
started talking to some of these
politicians right we're gonna do this
the guy is a politician he's got a bow
tie yeah that's a bow tie the issue is
that the politicians the only way they
can get elected the women vote for them
so the reason we can't see a change in
these laws
um you know where men can't get access
to their children where single mothers
are being paid to be single mothers all
of these horrible policies is because
the politicians can't change them
because they won't be reelected